I became a photographer because I wanted  to change the world I mean that was you  know that was the whole point  explorers to me were these superhumans  who couldn't do these things people  still come to me and they say isn't that  a man's job to dive in as a scientist I  had to make my own door but it never  occurred to me that I couldn't or  shouldn't it was there to be done we're  gonna have opportunities over the next  decade to understanding huge emetic  disease I was a first woman of color to  be an anchor at ESPN first journalist to  talk to Barack Obama  I've been shot at and tear-gassed and  lost at sea so yeah that would probably  be a typical day you need to really  empower women for conservation to work  all around us he can change people's  minds women can then make choices better  choices then  have a better world a better humanity  leaders heroes Glamour magazine called  me a camera totally badass in Kiwi  women of impact